well we saw two movies tonight we saw
Pacific Rim and the theater was
completely empty and we saw grown-ups
too and the theatre was completely
filled what does that tell us about
America it scares me so grown-ups 2 is
the sequel to growing ups with Adam
Sandler playing around with his friends
again and I think the grown-ups movie in
the first place was pretty much an
attempt at proving what they could do
with zero talent and zero story and
they're just like hey everyone come
together we don't have a script let's
just shoot it and see if America comes
to the movie theater it's just basically
kind of a mishmash of like you said
failed rejected Saturday Night Live
skits or whatever and features many
actors from Saturday Night Live and you
get sob viously I'm saying this bringing
all those friends together to do another
one let's have them all the same spot
again let's work up some crazy schemes
and some basically gags and ch one stick
they kind of just go about one day in
their life but there's really no point
like they go to Kmart they go practice
football they jump off a cliff naked and
then they have a 1980s themed party and
a fight with Taylor Lautner
yeah that's grownups - yeah every one of
Adam Sandler's friends in the film at
some point like they're like I leaned
over to him and I was like I'm just
waiting for Steve Buscemi and like two
scenes later Barry what's up and then
Shaquille O'Neal pops up right which is
nice I guess when I go into movie like
this I know what I'm expecting I'm not
walking into an Adam Sandler comedy
thinking like this is gonna be amazing
or it's gonna be great unfortunately
because I used to really like his
comedies on the night Billy Madison
happy gilmore it goldish it boom his
comedies were kind of similar back then
you know they were very sophomoric I
don't know if it maybe it was because I
grew up with it or not they did seem a
little bit more like they actually were
trying and now it's just like let's just
get these guys in this shot and try to
make it look nice yeah let's just do
that
bland formula that gets people in the
theater and make them think that they
see in a good movie the only risk this
movie really takes is really they try to
push the limits of how stupid the
audience is at times I'm not gonna lie
there's a few funny moments in this
movie a couple and then that that
comedic moment is ruined by that stupid
writing and the stupid fart joke that
they feel like they have to include
every 10 minutes in the movie yeah it
was true because there were a lot of
gags
where there would be a joke and I
like you know what that actually wasn't
awful like okay I got a chuckle out of
that but then like you said there'd be
like an added thing at the end of the
scene to kind of cap it off then made it
just go yeah
Oh poopy oh effort jogo a burp and a
fart at the same time that's comedy gold
folks um a few things I liked about the
movie that's kid would be a little bit
positive for about three seconds here
you cover that section oh I don't really
have anything um I was playing hey
that's fair enough I was pleasantly
surprised how bad the movie was I'm not
saying it's a great movie or a good
movie even a few funny things was David
Spade's son in this movie who is like
six foot five it looks like a cheap
version of Thor who wears flannels it's
just an excuse to get all of these
Hollywood actors into one spot and try
to create some incredibly over-the-top
movie and I don't really have a problem
with that like I'm fine with laughing
it's sophomore comedy they were jokes in
the movie that I thought were funny it
just none of it actually makes sense
like continuity is totally out the
window like from one scene will be let's
just put David Spade in a tire and throw
him down a hill and let's have vomited
out 20 feet afterwards yes a CGI tire
yeah exactly
Adam Sandler knows how to at least
please the male audience even if it's a
terrible movie at least gives you a
little bit of eye candy yeah he does and
then all of a sudden you get to have a
male cheerleader car wash as well so I
mean it's like you said they give you a
demon yeah and then they put some crap
to top it off and that's exactly what we
get with grownups too it's just I'm
sorry that this I did not like this
movie at all like I I can tell you guys
I can honestly tell you that I would
have probably hated this movie if I
hadn't seen it with you like it added
something yeah we could at least be like
wow this is truly off hey they're really
fucking stupid that's that's what this
movie had going for you know yeah seeing
it with somebody helps a little bit and
I think that's fair enough to say that
most companies have you said they're in
a dark room watching a comedy movie
first of all is it grace is it a little
bit depressing in the first place but
you know I watching it with somebody
else it adds a little bit of humor a
little bit you know you can at least
enjoy the movie in a bad way if you're
the kind of person that's gonna like
this movie then you're gonna like it
okay whatever him and/or I say to deter
you from going to grown-ups to it's not
going to matter you're gonna like this
movie there was a girl at our theater
all just packing up at every single joke
everything was perfect everything hit
for her if you're that type of audience
member more power to you go enjoy it but
anyone else probably is going to not
enjoy this
they just formulated this movie just to
be the most broad appealing movie ever
and it's a little bit watered down at
times but at little tokens you can see
these comedic geniuses that are in the
movie which are now they're in comas but
every once in a while they wake up for
just a second and they give you
something funny and then it's ruined by
the far jokes yeah
it's dumb I'm gonna get run ups to a
d-plus it's just it's just dumb and I
think I'm gonna give grown ups to a
c-minus you know if you watch the movie
alone I'd probably give it closer to
around addy but you know what I got a
few chuckles we made fun of it a few
times I think they added to the
experience um and that's grown-ups too
ha ha ha that way that sound just made
is like in grown-ups to a thousand times
yeah so guys thanks for watching I'm
here with my buddy John I'm staying at
his house in Indiana for a while we went
in saw Pacific Rim also tonight that
review is going to be on his channel
because I've already reviewed it you've
seen that we're going to go review that
on his channel the link is in the
description if you want to go check that
out
and as always guys if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck in
the night and get stuck my knives sticky
right there
Oh